welcome to this video playing Jimmy the
saint I'm pg3 out that works out Jimmy
the saint has no name player right yep
and as I recalled so we got some some
English opening here and the e5 set up
it's a very very decent setup for black
am i'm playing a wrong move over here I
think it was ok he couldn't really get
into five I want you to try to prevent
them um the d5 of course so I'm going
for that it should be 6 i'm going 93
yeah he's trying to go b5 and some cases
have some I'm trying to be ready for a
night move like night cc-64 I can go
before so let's go yo yo let's go that's
sir from The Ramones right yo let's go
is that the Ramones okay he's trying to
open stuff up but really quickly so
let's take them am I not winning a pawn
down this process
you and so I want that pawn but the
question is do I win the game in the
long run okay I think bishop is better
getting the bishop on an act of square k
you three let's not be so quickly and
yeah I think it's good done testicle 96
and this is not such a great square
anyway let's see what to do how can i
get rid of his active queen queen here
may be attempting to take a 97 does it
help no so we just basically accepts
that it's a loss end game okay let's see
here Bishop to before maybe and I guess
and that that could be a self-penned
let's not go into self pin with Ruby 8b
should be for now that should win a
second pawn right should win the e4 pawn
where you go a king a whoopsie 8 i'm
sorry about that ok didn't do that
so if I just grab this now and see a
problem there okay so push it back here
check yeah it's two points my ideas
efore and then look a seven would be
quite nice or just look ahead by the way
you KH is not bad okay this this way I'm
going you for now just push those pawns
up the board yeah okay protected person
how to how to resist them to get this
okay is there anything that you can do I
can also just play those kind of things
seagoing 492
now that would allow the check that's
not not necessary can go here though
what about cannot trap that night maybe
and threatening rook t2 and then either
strapped black resins Jim pretty
straightforward the game see and this is
a completely normal opening position I
don't quite I don't quite know the
details because I'm in this this type of
line of always screwing our move orders
i always forget how it is and correctly
played so he can actually take and this
is a mistake you should take here i see
hmm that's a bit awkward cannot move
that rook have to go queen a for them
mmm Queen 84 is okay it's a bit as equal
it's equal of course well this is
probably mostly just just blundering on
okay I'm just a part of its got no clear
way of getting it back this is a bit
tougher than the game this is
recommended by the engine I don't
understand the move what is the point
wants to give that back and go here I
doubt that I would have played that or
let me nai basically no I wouldn't have
play like that and this is now pretty
straightforward I think it's also much
better to take with the bishop they are
not eat with the pawn I mean this is
also quite ok but the bishop is just
strong on d5 get that out and here well
I was thinking he shouldn't take but
somehow he did TI n97 is answered by
patiently five that's the line that I
saw so here and now I get the open file
rook a one is no good because of this
don't want that to happen GM the pretty
pretty straightforward technical job and
I don't think I slipped up ok that was
ok thanks for watching